fans of the marvel cinematic universe
have already had to wait an extra
six months to see scarlett johansson
star in the black widow movie
and if the current release date finally
holds they'll be waiting a bit longer
the original avengers first solo movie
was pushed back once again to may 7th
2021
thanks to a series of coveted 19 induced
delays
it's really not that complicated
i got red in my ledger i'd like to wipe
it out
what's been known for a long time is
that the film was intended to be set
after the events of captain america
civil war
but before avengers infinity war and end
game in addition to johansson
it stars florence pugh as yelena belova
another black widow who underwent
training in the red room
rachel vice as molina vostokov an
experienced widow and david harbor as
alexei shostakov
a russian super soldier known as red
guardian little is known about the
film's main villain
the master armored taskmaster we don't
even know the name of the actor playing
the role
despite the production setbacks the
steady drip of new information and
collateral materials from the film
continues to trickle in in this case
some new pictures have dropped that show
actor ot fagben lay in character as rick
mason
a character described by entertainment
weekly as a contact from natasha
romanov's past and a potential love
interest
the pictures appeared to originate from
marvel's black widow the official movie
special book
and were posted on twitter november 1st
by elena barnes
underscores wrinkled in among a number
of other behind the scenes shots of
stunts and other big action sequences
in one of these mason is chatting with
natasha outside a beat up looking
airplane
somewhere in a grassy field it certainly
appears as though she trusts him at this
point in the film
this is notable largely because mason is
one of the prime suspects to be
taskmaster
the comic version of taskmaster
possesses the wonderfully named ability
of photographic reflexes
which allows him to duplicate the
movements or fighting styles of someone
else after watching them
basically after some time in the film
room he can teach himself to shoot a bow
like hawkeye throw a shield like captain
america
or fight like black a widow based on
portions of the trailer that seemed to
show him fighting with both a bow
and a shield it seems fair to say that
cinematic counterpoints will operate
much the same in practice
if it turns out to be mason under the
mask it looks like it will come as a
surprise to natasha
what's the spy that hasn't been double
crossed by someone they trusted this
wouldn't be the first case of a trusted
colleague betraying a marvel character
haircare wouldn't even be the first
portrayal executed on a remote airstrip
in the mcu's history
still there's a reason taskmaster's true
identity is still up in the air and
that's because there are more suspects
whatever linked to natasha rick mason
ends up having it likely won't be as
close as that of foster cough
who is described as a mother figure to
romanov and beloveda
vastakov is likely already a skilled
combatant and if she were imbued with
taskmaster's unique abilities they would
make her a formidable threat to natasha
the mcu has a long and redundant history
of family conflict so there's a pretty
good chance we'll see this theme once
again
fittingly enough fagben leia's already
dropped and deleted a pair of possible
hints on social media
one where he included a hashtag tm in a
post about his role in the movie
and one reference to the conspiracy
theory that he's taskmaster in a video
on
instagram live the other photos are not
much help resolving these mysteries
one shows mason leaning against the same
plane without natasha in the frame while
another depicts mason in a different
outfit
and only confirms his character's love
of plaid flannels
whether that makes him more or less
likely to be black widow's evil
mastermind you'll have to wait until at
least
may of 2021 to see check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite marvel
movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you